foreign
let's go to Seth in Tampa what's up Seth
hey good morning John how are you I'm
good my brother what's up
oh kind of hoping for some guidance in
some direction I'm at a uh a point in my
life that one I never thought I'd be in
and two I have no idea how to navigate
through so I was hoping for some help
cool man uh pull up a seat dude what's
up
divorced
um it was
told you know it's need to try a
separation and then about so I moved out
of the house and about two weeks later
she told me she was filing for divorce
why what happened what led to that
honestly uh I don't really know I've
asked several times I was told there's
uh she was seeking a sense of
Independence she's always been in
relationships she wants to do life on
her own grow on her own
there was I was actually listening to
last caller and I can certainly relate
to a lot of what you guys talked about
you know there was a lot of things that
we didn't discuss out of fear or
um afraid of you know stepping on others
toes so there was a lack of
communication
I've been trying to wrap my head around
what I could have done or what I did
wrong I don't know certainly know it's
what I could have done better because at
this point it doesn't really matter but
um I'm just trying to learn from it can
I tell you this
um I think uh
a friend my friend Randy pointed this
out to me years ago and it stuck with me
um
I I applied for a job once also like he
did and I was the Lone finalist and they
went with nobody
they just called and said it wasn't the
right fit and I remember thinking good
gosh they would rather have nobody than
me
that was worse than being one of three
finalists and having them pick somebody
else right because like they I don't fit
you all chose nobody over me here's why
I tell you that
that is super painful
it's one thing if you were abusive or
you screwed up or you cheated on her and
she's I I'm out of here because then you
can point to a thing
it's harder when you are left in a wisp
of smoke
and here's what I want to caution you
against I know we haven't gotten into
the end of the call I want you to
caution you against trying to get inside
her head and figure out why she did what
she did
the fact that she left your marriage and
left you standing there and Can't Tell
You Why
is all you need to know about the
caliber of person you're working with
here
it's a person who's entirely inward
focused on themselves and themselves
only
and that's devastating and heartbreaking
because she chose nothing over you
and that's hard and you just gotta
grieve the crap out of it
is that fair
yes I've been trying to work through the
The Grieving I've been allowing myself
times throughout the day to good when it
when it hits me to cry get angry good
you know and process this stuff and I've
been I've been sticking close to my
my support group and they've been
awesome I've also been isolating and
eating which is another side of it it's
uh
I just at this point I feel like I've
got
I no longer have uh Direction on what to
do in life like just a quick
backstory or whatever history is
when we got together
um we drink together heavily a lot and
then six years ago you know next month
God willing all six years sober
we got sober so
we've been you know ups and downs and
have gotten through the first years of
writing it was very interesting in our
household I bet man
because you know both of us you know I I
can say I'm you know I'm an alcoholic
and
I said Thank God next next month you
know God willing off six years sober so
I've had a lot of stuff to work through
and that's what I thought if we could
get through that kind of stuff you know
there's and we can get through anything
and those were the discussions that we
had
and it was rough but it seemed like
everything had gotten better and
you know for a long time I had alcohol
as my distraction and whatever other
substances and then that went away and
then I kind of had my wife is my
distraction and my husband is as my
identity and now that's been taken away
and it's like
I just I feel lost I feel like right now
and I'm in the process of trying to find
a new home so it's like to start a new
life or start life over I guess and I
just kind of feel like I'm in purgatory
right now just kind of waiting in this
in between it's like I want to heal and
move forward
maybe I'm trying to rush it I don't know
but it's like I'm just so stuck without
Direction I have no idea what I like to
do I don't know what happened yeah
so I'll I'll tell you this you're not
going to like my answer but you're right
where you need to be
you're not crazy okay you're not crazy
and you're not broken or dysfunctional
or you aren't the guy whose wife walked
out on him
who's also wrestling with sobriety and
um
who feels lost
you are surrounded by a cloud of
witnesses my brother okay
you're not crazy
um in these moments when everything feel
like you feel completely untethered from
every you were unhooked from love you
were unhooked From Desire you're
unhooked from safety you're unhooked
from your ride or die you're unhooked
right
yes you have opened your eyes up on the
plains of Kansas and your tribe left you
okay
these are actually the worst times to
get existential
because your body's in fight or flight
this is the best time to make a list a
very detailed list of little wins and
get through every day
and what you're going to find is I will
wake up at this time I will go to work I
will exercise I will call go to my group
I will not miss a meeting you don't care
if you've not been in a while I'm gonna
start going to meetings again I will
call my sponsor I will eat somewhat
reasonably I will go shoot pool and hang
out whatever the thing is and then that
day's over and then I'm gonna get up and
I'm gonna do it again I'm gonna get up
and I'm gonna do it again and what
you're gonna find in 30 days 60 days 120
days is the light starts coming back on
what most people do is they sit in that
in that black hole and they wait for the
light to come back on and it never does
see what I'm saying yes sir I wish there
was a way to think your way out of where
you are and there's not
you have to act
and that's the worst when that black
curtain Falls right
yes sir and let me tell you this stop
saying God willing
don't drink
is that cool
yes I know that's part of the language
and I know that's part of the thing but
I want you just to say I'm not drinking
yeah there's nothing worth it going back
to that no miserable life oh
you are not who you once were man
so let me ask you this crazy and I just
said don't get existential but
what like
drop your shoulders for a second and
just like free flow with me for a minute
like who do you want to be
and not profession wise I'm talking
about like you want to be a guy that
laughs a lot you want to be a guy that
like people think is a as a hunk you
want to be a guy that can fix stuff like
who do you want to be
I mean you kind of just nailed it right
on the head I mean I just I enjoy
I'm finally getting to a point where I
would you know enjoy life and
and I like riding motorcycles I like
working on
uh our engines and just doing stuff with
my hands and
yeah it's nice being a sober productive
member of society
but beneath that you know what it's what
it's even nicer
deciding what you want and deciding what
you need and then going to make that
happen
and when you are doing if you were your
needs are being met and you're doing
things that you love
all of us in society benefit
what you've been doing for a long time
you nailed it on the head you traded
alcoholism for codependency you traded
alcohol addiction for love addiction
yes and that's cool I mean it's a it's a
better addiction right it's at least
that's a lot it's it but it's it's it's
exposing right You're vulnerable because
now when love Cuts themself off from you
or unplugs from you man
it's you're back to you're back to day
what is it what's the what's what's the
death day is it day 15 day 16
um those first 30 days when you're like
I can't make this and you're like going
minute by minute remember those days
that's where you are right now yes
having to look at myself in the mirror
and be okay with with who's there no
distractions yeah man that's that's the
worst man right
so here's what we're gonna do over time
we're gonna build a life that includes
Joy and we're gonna build a life that
includes love again because you will and
you're going to build a life full of
friends and community
but not today
okay today's about grief
today's about reconnecting with people
in today's about doing today the best
you can and tomorrow you can do tomorrow
the best you can
and for you it's going to be both
it's cool because you've walked this
path before
and it's in some ways it's like the
person who lost 50 pounds and gained
back 60 and now they're going on a diet
again
it's so frustrating you gotta walk this
road again but here you are
is that fair
yes sir it's just annoying that you got
to do it again but let me ask you this
What alternative do you got
none I'm not going back to that yes sir
other life can I ask you this are you
good man
yes
you're a good guy
yes you treat people well
yes you tip well at the restaurants
yes you pick up a toilet seat when
you're in a public restroom
with my shoe but yeah yeah I don't care
what don't do it don't do it with your
mouth yeah don't do with your hands
weirdo yeah do with your feet that's how
I do it too
yeah man you're a good guy
and when you look in the mirror you
don't have to be like I like you I don't
always like myself but I do have to be
honest and say I'm a good guy
doing the best I can with the hand that
got dealt and now it's time to
play another way or learn a new thing or
to get a little bit better at this thing
or to but that starts with falling a
path man so what's tomorrow going to
look like for you
I can lay it out for me you're gonna
wake up and then what
um
normal is Regina is just waking up uh
getting a cup of coffee and getting
ready for work
after we have been getting back into the
gym so
do that immediately after work before I
get distracted with anything else
otherwise I'll talk myself out of it oh
dude will you commit to not missing for
30 days straight
yes promise yes we have like 16 and a
half listeners and I say half because I
think somebody's got a kid that listens
so the accountability Is Not Great Seth
but you just told everybody for 30 days
and on the days that you don't go lift
heavy because you don't you don't do
that back to back just go ride the bike
for 10 minutes do something but just
commit I'm gonna do something because
I'm worth doing something or I'll go for
a walk in my neighborhood but I'm gonna
do something for every day for 30 days
is that fair
I can do that yes will you reach out to
somebody every day for 30 days call a
friend
absolutely promise
yes are you back in meetings
oh yeah yeah actually they have
increased substantially absolutely it's
been a great thing good dude you are
I hate to tell you this you were in the
right place
and I know that doesn't I I hate to tell
you that because it doesn't make the
hurt go away right now
um you miss her huh absolutely
but I also you know the more I process
this and kind of like you had touched on
earlier it's like
you know I had
set expectations that or uh maybe
Concepts or thoughts you know
of the person
who she is and you know people change
and grow and you know my expectations
aren't weren't being met and that's
um you know that's something I'm dealing
with but maybe she's not the person I I
I don't I don't know uh I can't I it's
something it sounds clear to me that
she's not who you thought she was
yeah or that in the same way you weren't
didn't have the skills to articulate
here's what I need here's what I want
and here's what I'm missing and here's
where I'm scared here's where I feel
alone yes she didn't have those same
skills either
and the the demon beneath communication
you know every marriage thing is I gotta
communicate I got to communicate beneath
that is
feeling completely alone in a bed you
share with somebody
right
and the human need for connection is too
great it will it will be met somewhere
or in some way
all I have to say is this stay out of
her head you're never going to get a
clear answer she may not have a clear
answer as to why she felt like she had
to go
stay in your head
and in the head of your friends and
those who said I'll stick with you I'll
keep riding with yourself which may be
your immediate guys at your meeting by
the way the meeting's talking about this
AAA meetings
um the guys that you're meeting are
celebrate recovery meetings
um the guys at your meetings your
friends your counselor whoever that
happens to be your buddies at work
whatever that looks like
um
ride with him I'd also recommend dude
two things go to Walmart this afternoon
or Walgreens or Target or whatever buy a
cheap little
journally thing like I got here you
should probably have one of those um if
you've been doing a for a while and get
a deck of cards like uh like note cards
it's like a dollar and just commit for
30 days I'm gonna write down here's what
I'm gonna do today I'm gonna wake up and
have coffee I'm going to meditate for
one minute I'm gonna write five things
I'm grateful for I'm gonna get to work
five minutes early so I don't I'm not
rushed and crazy I'm gonna go to the gym
write those things down and mark them
off and all we're doing is we're winning
every day that's it we're gonna win the
day and then go to the next win the day
go to the next is that fair yeah yes sir
brother I'm I'm I I can hear I'm
heartbroken with you
I'm heartbroken with you
my promise is if you take care of the
little days and you're honest about your
feelings over the next five six months
the light will come on so bright you'll
see you'll laugh at how clear the path
ahead is
okay but you gotta take care of the
little days
I can do that is that cool yes sir
absolutely hey I'm I'm as proud of you
as I've been anybody in a long long time
thank you uh
you're walking through life dragging a
heavy sled behind you pretty good pretty
impressive
is that fair
yes sir absolutely cool
cool at some point
you can take that sled off you're gonna
walk free you're gonna walk clear
you'll you'll stand about six inches
taller that's not today
is a day to grieve and be sad and be
with your brothers sorry my man sorry